is there a possibility In Our Lifetime
that aging could be suspended the
dysfunction of gene expression the wrong
proteins expressed at the wrong time
really is kind of seems to be the core
driver of Aging we thought historically
maybe this was driven by mutations in
the DNA in cells that accumulate over
time and increasingly there's evidence
as published a few weeks ago in two
different papers it's an accumulation of
errors in the epigenome in cells
throughout the body now the exciting
science is what we talked about earlier
which is the set of yamanaka factor
these four molecules that have these
transcription factors that have been
proven to go in and help reset the
epigenome and if you apply enough of the
amanaka factors into a cell the
epigenome resets in a way that that
whole cell starts acting like a stem
cell and it turns out that you can
actually partially reprogram a cell